okay so uh the untrained mind gets into
patterns and so you can use patterns
against the person
so let's say like he's come in a few
times like
when you throw the front kick right or
maybe you're coming you throw the front
kick so
you get them in a pattern right now he
looks for the front kick
and if you hit him hard enough his body
reacts to the pain and so a lot of times
the hands just drop
out of a sympathetic unconscious squeeze
of his body okay
so once you've got him in a pattern then
what you're going to do is faint with
the front kick so
it looks to him like the front kicks
coming
but you're looking for the hands to drop
in that unconscious sympathetic squeeze
so i don't go deep into the front kick
i just fake the front face the butt kick
and come in with the knee jab
[Music]
faint with the front kick
so what makes it look like the kick's
coming
hips square the weight shifting
that i use on the front kick i keep as
much of the front kick as possible
without taking away from the lead hand
okay so
if i go deep into the front kick i took
away from the
from the lead hand if i don't go deep
enough it doesn't work
so it's deep interesting
[Music]
this is a bridging technique how do i
close this gap
without getting hit
okay let's go all right so last time we
were doing the
uh let's see i did you did the jab
and i boom and then he's coming back
with the rear headlock right
all right so he's doing the jab pulling
rear headlock and i'm moving
inside of this circle okay
i'm doing the same exact thing i'm
moving inside the one who's inside the
circle generates the spiral okay
so uh trap
post
move them out the leg will get light and
i now i'm going to move inside of this
circle that i'm generating here
so over i go here
and then i back up
trap so you don't need to grab it you're
just stopping him from posting out
hope that's what you're stopping so he's
got my legs
trapped trap
armpit bring the leg to you inside his
circle
you want to feel none of his weight or
his pressure okay
i'm not gonna take
here
[Music]
so
in the faint that that we threw
i reached the common ground between the
kick
and the forward progress of the jab
so i bring as much of the kick
and then in that common ground
is where the fake is to the gel
if i go past the common ground if i
complete
too much of the cycle of action of the
front kick
i take away from it and it's just a kick
followed by a left hand
you won't have the
effect you want
in your newaza
it was about fulfilling each cycle of
action so that you can operate inside
their cycle of action and that's what
you're doing here too
so i come around boom
if i don't have this
ground vector here but i have it like
this then i'm going to have to reach
over
and that is not marshall i'm not strong
enough to do that i don't have the
leverage
and i've exposed my rib cage to the
punch
so you have to complete the cycle of
action
then inside
here where it fits
if you if you do that his arms already
there you don't have to pull this down
so do the first cycle of action boom
inside here this hand hasn't done
anything yet because to do something is
to pull
this hand just takes his balance this
way
so as it takes his balance this way then
it brings the other hand
to where you want it to be then i just
keep guiding him
and he falls and i stay up with him
so complete your cycles no
no no these are all
young pulls so boom
here
you're feeling yourself totally you're
not doing it
find that inner space
here
[Music]
so that pull you want to do here or
here
do it on the front side of the circle
front side of the circle here
boom up not here
here
boom front side this room eating me
noggin
not here
keep going around his arm energy around
his arms
so
stay away from the chloe okay
so uh let's look at this
positioning here so what i want to do
is get this shoulder down lower
so if i go to pull this i don't really
do that
because that foot is the countering foot
that you should expect so when i grab
the elbow
and do a pulling a pulling action he's
going to get that foot under there
and then you're here
when i use the other hand and do a
turning action
this shoulder got lower it's harder for
that foot
it's not impossible athletes can get
that foot under the under there
okay but that's exactly what i want
because that sets up the shikaku on the
spiral
you should expect that they're gonna
step
so juan look to get that shoulder down
he's going to step do it as much again
and that
sets up the shikaku outside that foot so
stay there
so once he takes that step that's what
sets that up
so your uke is gonna it's gonna step now
and nothing should change for you but
they're
gonna try to resist that foot
try to resist okay
try to resist and yeah it's just
muscling them
instead
expect the foot and use the foot
how that energy falls back into you
so same way he pushes right and
he bounces off of the ground pop it's
the same thing here
boom he gets his foot on boom boom it's
just bouncing back into him
and then overpowering it
here
you guys resisting your technique
don't go for your gun right here at this
time you're behind the curb okay
but this way i get it
if you're going to if you're going to
see distance right
then it should be a culture projection
and not a push
so i'm not going to
and then again don't contest don't
contest
right field
okay let's go we're gonna take the gu
aspect out of it okay so
she's gonna come in i'm gonna seek this
contact here
okay so she's coming in i'm going to
catch the wrist and the elbow
and there's there's my ik adhesion
and then i'll come up top pull the pop
here okay
and then i'll draw my weapon
so key is you're not just slapping it
out of the way
and you're not just moving out of the
way i have to send her that way
so contact boom so with your adhesion
you do that
don't do it with your grout don't do it
with the okay
not even this grab here just keep keep
the thing going
boom pop and then you have your so
that's
that's gonna be the first technique
okay let's try okay this one goes to the
inside here
here's my contact point okay so my
adhesion is here
so here and here but with a striker okay
and then i move to the other there's
only sanctuary that i'm
well this is no different knife away
give your hands this is no different
than this okay
it's just my contact point let's go my
contact points are here
knife
oh here
there's not enough just to hit them i'm
going to get hit
maybe i don't have the effect on their
consciousness so
sure boom and forget
okay